Secretary Clinton won't you give her a
hand as she come
this is the day the Lord has made let us
[Applause]
because this is the day for the
homegoing celebration of a great man a
moral leader and a friend to Bishop
Walter Scott Thomas and first lady of
the church Patricia Thomas and the new
psalmist Baptist Church thank you for
welcoming us all here to reflect on the
life and celebrate the service of Elijah
Cummings and to the Cummings family to
his political family the constituents
from the Maryland congressional 7th
district thank you for sharing him with
our country and the world and
[Applause]
Thank You Maya as you have said so
beautifully you walked by Elijah's side
on this journey
thank you for your steadfastness your
resilience and your leadership it is no
coincidence is it that Elijah Cummings
shared a name with an Old Testament
prophet whose name and in Hebrew the
Lord is my god and who used the power
and the wisdom that God gave him to
uphold the moral law that all people are
subject to and because of all people are
equal
like the Prophet our Elijah could call
down fire from heaven
but he also prayed and worked for
healing he weathered storms and
earthquakes but never lost his faith
like that Old Testament prophet he stood
against corrupt leadership of King Ahab
and Queen Jezebel
and he looked out for the vulnerable
among us he lifted up the next
generation of leaders he even worked a
few miracles and he kept reminding us
life is no dress rehearsal the American
people want to live their lives without
fear of their leaders and as leaders we
have a responsibility to keep the
promises made when running for office to
make the lives of Americans better as
Elijah said while we're all on this
earth that's my message
our Elijah was a fierce champion for
truth justice and kindness in every part
of his life
[Applause]
his integrity and character his can-do
spirit made him a guiding light in the
Congress he pushed back against the
abuse of power he was unwavering in his
defense of our democracy he had little
tolerance for those who would party
ahead of country or partisanship above
truth but he could find common ground
with anyone willing to seek it with him
and he liked to remind of all of us that
you can't get so caught up in who you
are fighting that you forget what you
are fighting for even his political
adversaries recognized that it wasn't
really about politics for our Elijah he
led from his soul he often said that our
children are a message to a future we
will never see I saw that firsthand when
I attended an event for the Elijah
Cummings youth program in Israel
[Applause]
a leadership program for young people in
his district and Elijah didn't just put
his name on the program and then forget
about it he interviewed every applicant
he was personally invested in their
success he wanted all of us to see our
young people as he memorably asked us to
do when he gave the eulogy at the
funeral for Freddie gray did you see him
by the time these young people came back
from Israel to Baltimore
they had celebrated Shabbat study Hebrew
hiked up Masada they had seen and been
seen and made lifelong friends all
because Elijah Cummings knew from his
own experiences that it's one thing to
learn abstractly about the world but
another to experience it with people
different from yourself learning from
each other lifting each other up
you know Elijah often said his
philosophy was simple do something go
out and do something no matter how
daunting a problem seems no matter how
helpless you feel surely there is
something you can do I think that
remains his challenge to each of us as
he said even if it seems small there's
usually something you can do if you are
looking for it you can defend the truth
you can defend democracy you can lift up
others and toward the end of his life he
said I am begging the American people to
pay attention to what is going on
because if you want to have a democracy
intact for your children and your
children's children and generations yet
unborn
we have got to guard this moment this is
our watch our Elijah knew because he was
a man of faith and a man of the church
that life was fleeting
and precious and that's why he worked so
hard to make every moment of his life
count when we're dancing with the Angels
the question will be asked he said in
2019 what did we do to make sure we kept
our democracy intact
[Applause]
I will end with the paraphrase of a poem
that Elijah recited in his very first
speech in the Congress he said that he
told himself this poem as many as 20
times a day I only have a minute 60
seconds in it forced upon me I did not
choose it but I know that I must use it
give a count if I abuse it suffer if I
lose it only a tiny little minute but
eternity is in it thank you
Elijah Cummings for your work your
service and the lessons you leave us god
bless you
[Applause]